[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the iphone 8 review and yes i know
iphone 10 is like right around the
corner this is true but as of right now
this is the newest and best iphone so
here's the thing this is actually a
really great phone in a lot of ways but
it's going to tend to go under the radar
and really the only reason i'm telling
you to probably skip this
is because of that iphone 10. it's just
better but i'm going to try to review
this phone in a vacuum as if we don't
know that this is about to be one-upped
so this is everything you need to know
about iphone 8. so on the outside
aesthetically it's very similar to
iphone 7 of course same layout it's the
same dimensions actually so old cases
will work with it as well same camera
bump same general look it just looks
like an iphone again the one biggest
difference besides the new colors is the
glass on the back so this glass is a bit
heavier a bit grippier actually than
rounded metal and a bit more
fingerprinty naturally but most of all
it's more breakable than aluminum so
that's something to note even if you are
using the strongest glass ever apple
it's glass the thin finish is really
nice though as you'd expect everything
on the back of the phone is underneath
the glass so the apple logo is no longer
a cutout in the metal it's behind the
glass that iphone logo the text is
behind the glass even the dual flash is
under the glass so it's all smooth to
the touch but the main reason they went
with the glass is wireless charging so
iphone 8 now supports qi enabled
wireless charging through that glass so
any of those wireless charging pads you
see at starbucks or on those ikea tables
or at a samsung user's bedside table the
iphone can now use those too
nice
clearly not first but still nice it
doesn't have to be first to be nice in
fact it's really nice that the iphone is
getting qi enabled wireless charging and
not some proprietary standard because
that now means we're gonna start seeing
these qi wireless charging accessories
everywhere that work with all of the
phones that already support it i mean
think about it if the iphone can make
the apple watch an accessory
the most popular watch in the world
then seems like the iphone getting
wireless charging should also be able to
make that pretty popular too thanks
apple and also if you're thinking what
i'm thinking then yeah that's space gray
iphone 8 is another fingerprint magnet
for real uh reflections i can deal with
that's just something that's on every
glass phone fingerprints not so much
they show up a lot more on the space
gray but you can grab a dbrand skin to
cover that up and it might actually look
better
with the matte black than the glossy
space gray just throwing that out there
so i'll link this one below so around
the front the iphone 8 and 8 plus have
mostly the same displays as before still
ips still the same resolution and
everything but they now support true
tone which was something that was in
ipads before essentially what it does is
when you turn it on it adjusts the color
temperature of the screen to match the
lighting of whatever environment you're
in so under certain lights it makes the
display itself more yellow under other
lights it's closer to blue all of it is
to stay visually consistent to the eye
it's technically less accurate but also
tends to look better so i'm cool with it
i leave it on as long as i'm not editing
or like making something where accurate
color really matters really i'm just sad
there's no pro motion display no oled
display no resolution bump you know
still 1080p in 2017 seriously you could
say i'm even disappointed with the
display or lack of a display upgrade but
it is what it is it's still i guess the
best ips display in any smartphone also
the speakers are 25 louder on iphone 8.
honestly i don't hear much of a loudness
difference it sounds to me more like a
clarity difference these just sound
better but yeah everything else new
about the iphone 8 is on the inside and
that would be with the cameras and the
specs so when we originally got this
announcement i thought this would be
some pretty minor upgrades you know
slightly new camera bump we see that
every year and of course the new specs
the a11 bionic chip it'll be faster but
we may or may not notice that but these
two things have actually really
impressed me and turns out they've
actually enabled some things that
literally no other smartphone right now
can do the a11 bionic chip is
ridiculously powerful it is the fastest
chip in any smartphone right now and
it's not close the benchmarks show it
the everyday use shows it it's more
powerful and more efficient than any
other chipset which is awesome in a
phone so because of this number one
battery life has actually improved
significantly because of this efficiency
essentially it's not working as hard and
is smarter about what cores fire up when
so iphone 8 and 8 plus have really good
battery life in fact i'd say with the
five plus hours of consistent screen on
time i'm getting and a full day of heavy
use ending with 20
seems like this is back to being the
battery life king of the hill with the 8
plus and then everyday performance is
excellent i mean ios 11 is already
pretty smooth on a brand new phone
anyway but i made a separate video all
about its best features essentially
though it means that this is much more
future-proof a super high-powered chip
like this should ideally keep the phone
running smooth for years to come as apps
and services get more intensive a prime
example of that is all the new augmented
reality applications this stuff takes a
lot more processing power to run
smoothly but like this sky guide really
cool stuff like this has started to pop
up for ios that tracks really smoothly
shows a ton of information over your
real life and renders in high quality
color me impressed and then the super
powerful chip enables some seriously
impressive video features in the camera
that again you really don't see many
other places 4k 60 frames per second
video and 1080p 240 frames per second
slo-mo these are things you barely find
in any other smartphone let alone an
actual dedicated video camera right now
i mean the new gopro does it my red
camera does it but that's about it not
much else and it's not just that the
frame rates are high but the quality is
really good too 11 bionic has room for
much better dedicated image processing
and it's excellent with things like
noise reduction and high dynamic range
and contrast and sharpness and detail
and all of that now they are also
technically new 12 megapixel sensors so
i give them credit for that too it's new
hardware new cameras for both the 8 and
8 plus also put a new secondary
telephoto camera for the plus but wow i
did not think they would be this good
and yes it did get the highest ever
rating from dxomark but i wouldn't put
too much stock in the comparative
numbers there just know that photo
quality has taken a noticeable step up
and even though the next google pixel is
right around the corner and iphone 10
with slightly better glass is also
incoming the photos i've gotten from
this phone have pretty much cemented it
in the top five smartphone cameras of
this year it's that good right off the
bat if you're into photography iphone 8
will not disappoint there's also the new
improvements to portrait mode on the 8
plus so you can now take these portrait
photos and adjust the portrait lighting
effects during or after you've taken the
photo and they try to mimic different
types of contrasty lighting if you're
trying to take that to the next level
they're a little bit interesting uh the
first few actually do a pretty decent
job i think they're likely to get better
with software updates in the future the
last two though with the super dramatic
stage light they kind of look a bit more
like cartoon cutouts if you don't get
them perfect so i would advise to i
guess use them sparingly unless you want
to be the first one with that stage
light profile picture so yeah the camera
is really good the performance is really
good the battery life is on point i mean
there's not a whole lot to complain
about with these new phones
except the fact that the design is so
brutally outdated for 2017 in this price
point in fact i saved all my complaints
here for the end of the video ready it
gets a little bit too warm when wireless
charging i mean other phones i've used
in the past couple years also get warm
to varying degrees when they're on the
charging pad iphone is definitely near
the high end of that spectrum and
wireless charging isn't perfect you need
contact with that pad and as soon as you
want to use the phone and pick it up it
stops charging unless you pick up the
phone and the charger every time but
that's not unique to the iphone it
doesn't come with the usbc fast charger
in the box iphone 8 is capable of some
really fast charging speeds with usbc
but it won't get those speeds with the
out of the box wall adapter you need to
pay extra for that that's pretty lame i
wish they used this entire huge bezel up
at the front to put a real front-facing
speaker even if it's only one side of
the phone this earpiece really isn't
that loud it's not adding much it will
be better than nothing right now it's
kind of weak and for this price of
course i wish the display was oled i
wish it was a higher resolution too i
wish it was a bit brighter but really i
wish it got a lot closer to the edges
i'm overall just kind of bored with the
screen and the design at this point and
of course it still does not have a
headphone jack
yeah obviously i can't pretend i think
that's coming back but i have to say it
it doesn't have one so that's iphone 8.
is it boring heck yeah you could say
it's boring especially on the outside
we've seen it before but for that a11
bionic chip for us nerds that really is
something else i mean i'll say it again
it really is actually a great phone but
the only reason i'm telling you to skip
this one is because we know iphone 10 is
coming out in like a month i'd say the
only reason to get this phone over the
upcoming iphone 10 is if you really want
to save the 200 bucks which a lot of
people will or if you just absolutely
have to have a smaller device that
iphone 10 does have a pretty big display
so this is actually smaller than that
or if you just really really need to
keep touch id for some reason but really
a big part of why apple made this phone
and sort of fit it in with the iphone 10
and the other prices so they could offer
a phone and iphone at each of these
major buying prices all of these are for
sale on apple.com right now and that's a
nice even spread it's a gradient of
prices to offer an iphone for any budget
so the timing is kind of weird with
iphone 8 coming out right before iphone
10 and it's probably very tempting to
pick up iphone 8 but you already heard
what it said so to spring all this money
right now for what's about to be the
second best iphone i mean it's not a bad
phone but when the better one's clearly
around the corner
seems like it's an obvious choice to
recommend that one feels weird to tell
you to skip a great phone but there you
have it but hey even if you do go with
iphone 8 you probably won't be
disappointed
there you have it thank you for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]